Do a die hard sneak around use air vents you've
never seen die hard i'm 17 no i've never seen
die hard well neither did the guy in die hard
so you're nailing it welcome back everyone it's
charlie this will be my full rick and morty season
six episode two video there are a whole bunch of
easter eggs and references so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel i'm doing
videos for all the episodes be sure to subscribe
to get them careful for spoilers for the episode
if you haven't seen it yet we'll start at the
beginning and work our way through shot by shot
talking about easter eggs and wtf moments as we go
along starting with the episode titled rick a mort
well lived which is a reference to the buddhist
phrase a life well lived now people have heard
that phrase is a lot all over the place it was
originally from the buddha's medisuda a teaching
on treating all beings with kindness and care
which is basically the theme of the episode where
all the mortys in this roy game just want to live
their lives out in peace even though on a meta
level they're all fractured pieces of our morty's
one consciousness and that's why everyone speaks
with morty's voice except for rick who's playing
as the roy character with marta morty the main
morty ending the episode by staying in the game to
live out her life the way that she wanted to pay
off the title have a life well-lived but inside
the game that was the secret bargain she made
with rick at the end in exchange for getting all
the rest of the morty's like all five billion plus
of them to leave the game he had to agree to keep
the roy game running long enough for her to finish
living out the rest of her life which is why in
the post credit scene the workers at blips and
chits wheel the game with its own power supply to
make sure that it stays on into the very indiana
jones-looking warehouse that's full of massive
piles of stuff you can let me know if you spotted
any other particular easter eggs in the background
here like it seems like there's a me seeks box but
i couldn't spot any specific easter eggs besides
that after which they joke about remembering where
they put it because everything in the cavernous
warehouse is digitally cataloged and backed up so
it doesn't really matter where they put anything
they'll be able to find it no matter what a joke
about the military in the indiana jones movies
like how do you find anything in this warehouse
they're all in the same looking boxes the cold
open of the episode is the reveal that they're
stuck inside the roy game at blips and chips
with everyone on the planet containing a piece
of morty's consciousness because the game fritzed
out when the terrorists attacked in a special
cameo seen by peter dinklage of game of thrones
tyrion fame i literally just did a house of the
dragon episode video where i talk a little bit
about tyrion but i didn't know that he was going
to cameo in this rick and morty episode so that's
a bit of a coincidence in the whole exterior part
of the episode in blips and chips like the b
storyline is a parody of the die hard movie with
both peter dinklage's group and summer separately
trying to pull a die hard do the plot of the movie
without each other knowing about it till they're
both fighting each other like are you doing a die
hard maybe are you doing a die hard maybe are you
doing a die hard maybe are you also more or less
basically do all the things that john mcclane
and the villains did in that movie separately
and based on the logic in the episode this is
canon now to the rick and morty multiverse all
these realities once every culture reaches a point
in the multiverse of rick and morty they produce
their own version of the die hard story in their
mythology and that's how these aliens knew about
the plot of die hard and were pulling a die hard
because he's also written several books on it
which they referenced in one of his books that
summer winds up reading on the can called the
nakatomi paradigm that's a reference to the
nakatomi plaza tower from the movie that it takes
place in which summer uses to learn the ending of
the movie and how to take the gun to her back and
win the scenario in some cultures it's called
tower man rick reveals he also knows about that
because he makes a reference to tower man at the
end of the episode another culture calls it the
thornburg cycle that's a reference to the richard
thornberg character in the die hard movie like in
one of the cultures he's like the main character
of their die hard mythology another culture in the
multiverse calls it foolish to imagine you'd be
able to kill which is a reference to a particular
line of dialogue from the actual movie and one
of the funnier reveals is that at the end of
the episode after they both make it out of the
game they reveal that this is not rick's first
die hard like he makes a reference to it at the
beginning of the episode telling summer to go do a
die hard but he himself has already been through
similar scenarios like this in other cultures
because when peter dinklage's alien sees him he
recognizes him as dr oz elysium like rick has
become a legend in his culture's die hard mythos
the other joke is that they do the whole plot of
die hard as a tongue-in-cheek version of like a
cliff's nose version like if you asked a child
who had never seen die hard to explain the plot
that's basically what they did in the episode
which is also a bit of a meta reference to the
actual rick and morty tv show because it was
originally inspired by back to the future it was
called doc and marty so it's like summer in the
episode is pulling a version of the doc and marty
version of back to the future like when she runs
around at the episode killing all the aliens using
die hard as an actual catchphrase just repeating
the line that's also meant to be a reference
to john mcclane's yippee kaye catchphrase
as they reveal what's going on with all the mortys
in the game over the course of the episode all
the different mortys well the people start to
eventually shave their heads wear morty clothes
so that even though they all have very different
bodies and faces some are women some are old men
they all slowly start to look more like morty dan
harmon in the writer of the episode said this is
also where they started to parody the organized
religion and cults aspect of the episode like the
mortys in the game slowly start to turn it into a
cult we're all part of this larger greater cosmic
force that also just happens to be a 14 year old
boy and we're all just video game characters which
is why the main morty marta says her video game
parents don't actually know anything about judaism
because they're just versions of morty and
morty never learned anything about being jewish
they also make a joke about that with the news
broadcast later it's called good enough news
which is why when he's trying to report the news
he does a really bad job of it rick also makes a
lot of jokes throughout the episode about how
all the crazy things that all the different
mortys get up to are going to be even funnier in
the end because really it's just morty doing bad
things to himself ha you'll know how funny that
is when we get back some of the mortys know the
truth and don't want to leave like the president
of the united states the reason why this isn't the
keith david looking version of the president even
though he'd have morty's consciousness is because
when they visit the president 50 years has gone by
in the game so the original keith david version of
the president would have already served out his
terms a long time ago they do make a lot of real
world political jokes too when he talks about a
bunch of people being united under a big bag of d
the reason why they say that morty was fractured
into a little over 5 billion people instead of
like the 8 billion that should normally be
on earth like if it was a version of earth
there'd be a little over 8 billion people alive i
think either what happened is that there's only a
little over 5 billion people on this planet or
what happened is they're just saying that there
are a little over 5 billion people who have brains
that are capable of housing a portion of morty's
consciousness when rick comments to the other
morty's about losing followers every time he
has to explain the truth to them that's just a
joke about how some of the mortys don't want to
believe the lie like they want to actually be part
of this cult he also makes a get schwifty episode
reference when he says he's an old-school hip-hop
man his joke about missing the mark on diversity
is because most of the morty's here are white and
because he represents most of the people on the
planet you should see like a much wider variety
of mortys here also there's the idea that they're
all starting to resemble morty like they're
making themselves look more like morty does
in real life so everybody looking the same would
be like the opposite of diversity when rick tries
to tell the military morty that there's no
god even in the real world that's actually
a reference all the way to the pilot episode
oh my god my parents are so loud i wanna die
there is no god summer you gotta rip that band-aid
off now you'll thank me later within the rick and
morty multiverse there are higher level cosmic
beings that he's gone up against but no actual
one true god even the version of jesus they did
on the show was like a fictional version within
the context of this one particular scenario so
it wasn't meant to be a real version even though
the real devil is canon to rick and morty that
doesn't prove that god exists by association i
think until rick acknowledges that god exists on
the show he doesn't exist on the show so to speak
we'll see if he finally bends in that direction by
like season 10 or season 100 however many seasons
rick and morty winds up going 100 years rick and
morty then we'll finally prove god's existence
you notice once marta talks him down and he
realizes the truth he starts talking like
morty they all start talking like morty's saying
oh geez over and over again oh jeez come here
oh geez come here geez also his character had a
very loose understanding of his backstory in a
war because morty in real life doesn't really know
that much about world history like he doesn't do
that well in school that's why he calls it a
generic overseas war back in blitz and ships
one of the aliens is named winslow which is
a reference to reginald veljohnson's die-hard
character who's actually mostly known for playing
carl winslow on family matters when they're doing
the montage around the world to all the different
mortys and different cultures i love that a bunch
of awakened mortys who know the truth are now
going to see peep shows together also morty is
such a big horn dog that a bunch of these mortys
are just willing to get it on with each other
knowing the truth like they're just getting it all
with themselves technically but they don't care
then he sort of explains the logic of the scenario
like what happens with morty losing pieces of his
consciousness which they pay off at the end of the
episode because every time in the game one of the
people dies a piece of morty's consciousness
dies like a fraction dies and eventually those
fractions add up by the end of the episode marta
is the only person who stays in the game so it's
like that one little piece of morty that he winds
up losing the funny way they pay that off though
is that when they come out of the game morty
says immediately oh rick i trust you implicitly
let's go great so the part of himself that he
lost was the portion that didn't trust rick
which is kind of convenient for rick going forward
and convenient for the show i think it's their way
of sort of soft rebooting the morty character to
more like a season two type of morty as opposed
to the more mistrustful version during season
three like we're gonna clip out this one little
piece of morty's personality and he's gonna be
a little bit more like he was during season two
rick complains about not having enough pockets in
his roy form which explains another reason why he
always wears that lab coat he makes a justice
league snyder cut joke saying eight percent of
it was just batman dreaming that was a reference
to the end of the movie with the nightmare scene
of that potential future that batman was seeing
in his dreams that he woke up from at the end
which morty claims he doesn't understand meaning
he hasn't seen the snyder cut but also that means
the snyder cut is now canon to rick and morty
they just did a bunch of brand new vindicator
shorts and the vindicators team themselves were
meant to be a big parody of all superhero movies
like the marvel avengers movies the dc justice
league when the mortys devolve into different
warring factions between the ones who want to
leave and the ones who want to stay the ones that
want to stay are called the stay publicans
and when rick is explaining the dangers of
dying inside the game he says that he'll be okay
dying in the game but morty would be screwed we've
actually seen what happens when rick dies he just
reboots his consciousness in another backup body
sometimes in other realities which they use for
the plot of a previous episode but morty doesn't
have those kinds of backup copies available
to him rick could go pull a replacement morty
from another reality but it wouldn't be his same
morty that he's been with the past couple seasons
which they also just made a joke about with jerry
like we've had the wrong jerry for the last couple
seasons when peter dinklage's alien finds rick
and morty at the roy game one of the aliens
starts playing the actual music from die hard
it's beethoven's ode to joy it gets used in tons
of movies and tv shows so you've probably heard
it somewhere before they reveal eventually marta
has had a child of her own who also gets part of
morty's consciousness and they argue about the
logic of the episode with her questioning whether
or not the next generation also becomes just like
hers with a piece of morty's consciousness i
think the answer is yes because the child also
speaks with morty's voice the way they explain the
end of the episode is that marta was the only one
left inside the game but you can always theorize
that maybe somebody else is alive inside there
and it winds up being kind of like a teeny verse
tiny verse situation with like a whole culture
rising up inside this digital game when the alien
says the quarterback is toast that's another line
from the die hard movie they both referenced the
end of the movie which summer has just learned
from reading the nakatomi paradigm book and then
they end the episode with rick calling out the
tower man reference implying that in the tower
man version of die hard in this other culture
that story ends with the exact same scenario
of one of the lesser villains killing the main
villain by eating him and then flying away and
then i explained what they did to morty in this
episode like this is canon now like he lost a
piece of himself but it was just the piece that
didn't trust rick we'll see how they reference
that during episode 3 next week and the actual
post-credits scene is just a straight-up parody
of the die hard 3 movie wait do i even do it
i wish my brother was still alive
in that movie the brother of the
main villain from the first movie tries to
pull off another heist and in this scene
this guy is the brother of peter dinklage's alien
character who then comments on how pointless it
is that they're trying to pull off die hard
3 like it's not as good as the first movie
and in that movie bruce willis is made to wear
a sign just like this which is why they make the
joke about it being super racist but if you
spotted any other easter eggs and references
in the episode that i didn't spot in the video
just write them below in the comments in my full
episode 3 video we'll post next week after they
release it everyone click here for my house of the
dragon episode 5 trailer video and click here for
my full rick and morty season 6 episode 1 video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!